hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to a
high-definition unboxing video and first
of all you might notice I'm doing this
unboxing live I guess to say it without
any sort of voiceover work you guys seem
to like that with the monitor unboxing
so I'll be doing it with this video
which is the cyborg rat 7 Gaming Mouse
of course it's more than a mouse it's a
rat unless you didn't get that pun but
I'll be doing this just because I'm a
little bit iffy about doing this one
live because of what I've heard about
the packaging but you can tell that this
is the the newest high-end gaming mouse
not the highest end there's the rat 3 5
7 and 9 the right 9 is just the wireless
version of this but you can see there's
at 5600 dpi
it's a back and forward button and a
roller I'll get to this all when I unbox
it but there will be a you know a
standard review of this mouse as well
you can see the packaging here is pretty
crazy all sorts of transformers and
specs about how adjustable it is and
there's the actual mouse itself so what
I'm gonna try to do live without any
sort of intense cutting it might be a
few cuts is to actually get into this
packaging and see how it goes so I'll be
using my not-so cyborg any more looking
mouse or knife I mean to try to get into
this there we go alright so like I said
this mouse took just about an eternity
to ship through Amazon and but it was
only about $75 in the very end with
shipping and everything so I think it
was worth the wait
so there's this plastic on top of the
mouse that is a really nice and matte
finish and I'm already pumped to get
into this so of course so there's going
to be some intensive packaging issues
with me getting these twist ties off so
I'll get to this in a second but of
course there is much more than that to a
gaming mouse package I'll see if we can
get behind this orange cardboard the
rest of the accessories that come with
the rad7 so I mean you guys asked for it
more live unboxings so there we go
alright so this right here you guys have
a driver CD this will give you all your
information
all your drivers windows 7 drivers you
might want to go to Mad Catz website and
check out the latest versions which is
what I'll be doing here's a little user
guide for the rat 7 and I guess a little
I guess more information about a little
promo with a little cyborg on it I like
the idea of it being a mouse a rat not
just a mouse what you guys have been
here on get this out is an accessories
an adjustment tool sort of pouch so
here's a capsule where you put all the
weights in the mouse to make it heavier
or lighter there's a pinky rest there's
a thumb rest and there's several other
backs there's a grippy one there's
another matte one so this mouse is
definitely really good with
adjustability and you can pretty much
customize this mouse however you want
and I'll show you guys that in the
review video and that appears to be just
about it in this box so I'm going to
move this off to the side and bring back
the actual rat I'm gonna start calling
out that from now on I'm gonna call it a
rat but yeah so when we show you guys
and basically what it looks like on my
desk it's part of the custom build I've
been talking to you guys about for god
knows how long it's been a really long
time since I actually first introduced
that and I'll be doing an actual
building series video when I actually
finish getting all the parts and begin
to put it together so as I get the parts
one by one I'm not actually putting them
together I'll be doing that when I'm
done gathering all the parts you might
have seen in Maya my giveaway video the
beats by dre
there was a phil velociraptors sitting
in the background those are the hard
drives I'll be using in raid but right
off the bat I am excited to use this
mouse it looks really really good first
of all there's a USB gold-tipped cord
this is a braided cord high high end USB
2.0 cord I know a lot of you guys don't
like wired mice but for gaming mice now
that I'll be doing a lot of gaming but
for a customizable high end Mouse this
is really good if you guys can hear that
clicking is really responsive here's the
scroll wheel up front kind of looks like
a transformer on the left hand side
there's a sniper button and if you know
what that is that's the precision aim
mode which slows down your curse
or epi count to get that perfect
headshot while you're moving a mouse
there's our forward and backward buttons
and you can program these of course with
drivers here you have a little scroll
wheel you can of course use this for
swapping through weapons if you're
gaming or something like that and of
course swapping through tools if you're
doing graphic work like I will be in
Photoshop cs5 if you turn the mouse
upside down you can see a whole lot more
there's the scroll wheel from below
you'll also get a little tool that you
can turn to move this in and out I'm
actually gonna go ahead and actually
I'll do that later because you need the
tool but if you take this and unscrew it
you'll be able to take this out and
here's where all your weights are those
are the weights inside of it so if you
can screw this whole thing wheel to take
weights out and make the mouse lighter
I'm not going to do that quite yet it
can you also use this tool that comes
out of the mouse to adjust this to make
it turn in and out and to attach more
parts such as a pinky rest etc so this
is a really really highly customizable
Mouse you might think it's ugly but
trust me you won't be looking at your
mouse as much as you are looking at your
screens which is why I'd advise you're
done that's a high end mouse which is
what you'll be using to interact with
your computer and a high end screen so
anyway this has been an extremely long
unboxing video but I'm glad to show you
guys this cyborg rat 7 gaming mouse or
gaming rat thanks for watching this
unboxing video peace